a mí siempre me sirve muchísimo ver
varios ejemplos así es que me imagino
que es una muy buena idea ver más
ejemplos de notación científica
y entonces lo que vamos a hacer en este
vídeo es escribir un montón de números y
después escribirlos poco a poco en
notación científica la verdad yo creo
que sí vamos a cubrir todos los casos
necesarios todos los casos que te vas a
encontrar por allí y después vamos a
hacer algunas cuentas vamos a hacer una
multiplicación y una división
connotación científica entonces pues
empecemos por escribir algunos números
vamos a escribir 0.00 852 aunque y este
es el primer número creo que lo hice muy
grande pero ya ni modo y por aquí vamos
a escribir 7 0 1 2
0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0
la verdad es que podría poner más ceros
pero detengámonos aquí entonces vamos a
escribir el tercer número vamos a poner
0 punto y muchísimos 0 2 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0
0 y el final vamos a poner un 5 y por
qué no 0 0 gay que no se nos olvide que
por aquí está el punto decimal y bueno
también queremos calcular cuál es la
anotación científica de 723 porque
aunque este sea un número muy chiquito
también tenemos que saber cómo calcular
la anotación científica de estos números
y por las mismas razones vamos a
escribir puntos 6 6 puntos 6 es en
realidad 0.6 y finalmente 8 2 300 000
000 entonces vamos a encontrar la
notación científica de este número si
queremos escribir algún número en
notación científica lo que tenemos que
hacer es encontrar la potencia de 10 más
grande que divide en este número aunque
hay que cabe dentro de este número y
para hacer eso lo que hacemos es buscar
el primer número distinto de cero de
izquierda a derecha aunque empezamos por
aquí hay 000 y este es el primer número
distinto de cero que ya que lo
encontramos lo que hacemos es ver
cuántos lugares tenemos que recorrer el
punto para que nos quede un solo número
distinto de cero a la izquierda del
punto aunque en este caso pues va a ser
este 8 aunque hay aquí movimos el punto
1 2
lugares 123 lugares en este caso también
tenemos que contar el lugar del otro
esto es igual a pues pusimos el punto
decimal a la derecha del 8 porque eso es
lo que tenemos que hacer entonces nos
queda 8.52 por 10 y ahora contamos la
cantidad de lugares que tuvimos que
mover el punto que fueron 123 entonces
aquí ponemos 3 pero como estamos
moviendo el punto a la derecha entonces
tenemos que poner un símbolo de menos al
igual que en la recta numérica se
acuerdan cuando teníamos lanita si salta
vamos a la derecha en el números
negativos entonces este número se
describe así en notación científica
bueno otra forma de ver esto es que si
tenemos aquí 10 a la menos 3 entonces lo
que tenemos son milésimas y aquí lo que
nos están diciendo es que tenemos 8.52
milésimas y si se fijan en este número
en efecto tenemos aquí ocho milésimas y
media pero bueno vamos con el siguiente
ejemplo vamos con este número t y para
hacer que todo se vea más sencillo vamos
a ponerle comas cada tres ceros ok para
escribir este número en notación
científica
buscamos el primer número distinto de
cero de izquierda a derecha en este caso
pues lo tenemos aquí luego luego es este
7 y entonces en notación científica esto
se escribe como 77 después ponemos un
punto y después todos estos números a la
derecha del punto decimal
0 12 todos estos 02 desaparecen porque
están a la derecha de un punto decimal
y esto lo tenemos que multiplicar por 10
a una potencia suficientemente grande
como para que nos recorra el punto
decimal suficientes veces a la derecha
para que nos quede este número aunque
eso ya sabemos cómo se hace a ver
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
números en la derecha de este 7 entonces
tenemos que multiplicar a este número
por 10 12 veces ok
12 veces aquella en realidad este 10 a
las 12 se vea se cuenta como un 1 en el
lugar donde está el 7 y puros ceros aquí
a la derecha de este 1 pero bueno ya
terminemos esta es la anotación
científica de este número y vamos con el
siguiente aquí que vamos a encontrar la
primera cifra distinta de 0 la cual es
entonces nuestro número va a ser 5 y
podríamos poner puntos 0 0 pero pues son
ceros a la derecha de un punto decimal
entonces en realidad nada más nos queda
el 5 y tenemos que contar cuántos
lugares tenemos que recorrer el punto
decimal hasta llegar aquí entonces
tenemos aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 y tenemos que incluir a este también
entonces tenemos 14 así es que tenemos
que multiplicar 5 por 10 a la 14
ahora vamos a escribir 723 aunque
parezca una broma para ti entonces
queremos saber cuál es la potencia de 10
más grande que cabe en 723 y pues esto
está muy fácil no sólo ponemos un 1 por
aquí y ponemos dos ceros en estos
lugares y ya sabemos cuál es la potencia
más grande de 10 que cabe por aquí y esa
es 100 para escribir 723
científica tomamos 723 y lo dividimos
entre 100 y nos queda 7.23 pero no se
nos debe de olvidar que tenemos que
también multiplicar por 100
estos dos números son iguales y bueno
para llegar a la notación científica nos
falta un pequeño paso que es escribir a
este cien de la forma correcta aunque
esto es igual 7.23 por cien es 10 al
cuadrado cierto bueno esta es la
anotación con la que tienen que terminar
entonces vamos con este otro número y
pues buscamos cuál es el primer número
distinto de cero y ese es este así es
que nos queda 6 por iu es alá y entonces
contamos cuántas veces tenemos como ver
el punto decimal para que nos quede un
solo número a la izquierda del punto
decimal y lo tenemos que mover un solo
lugar que estamos moviendo el punto
la derecha entonces es 10 a la menos 1
lo cual tiene todo el sentido del mundo
no porque 10 a la menos uno es 1 entre
10 entonces esto es igual a 6 entre 10
lo cual tiene todo el sentido del mundo
porque 6 entre 10 es igual a punto 6
cierto entonces vamos con este número
rápidamente de izquierda a derecha vemos
cuál es el primer número distinto de 0 y
ese es este y ahora queremos contar
cuántos números hay a la derecha de este
número
ok pero antes de hacer eso vamos a hacer
que este número se vea un poquito más
comprensible poniendo comets cada tres
números de derecha a izquierda y listo
entonces saber cuántos números hay a la
derecha hay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
entonces directamente sabemos que este
número se escribe como 8.23 por 10
el número de números que hay a la
derecha o sea 10 a la 10 bueno espero
que las razones detrás de esta anotación
científica hayan quedado muy claras en
el vídeo pasado podemos repasar la
rapidísimo y es que pues aquí estamos
buscando cuál es la potencia de 10 más
grande que cabe dentro de este número ok
y para encontrar esa potencia podemos
poner un 1 aquí en el lugar del 8 y
poner puros ceros en lugar de todos los
números que están a la derecha del 8
aunque hay pero está potencia de 10 la
podemos escribir en esta forma contando
la cantidad de ceros que tienen aunque
en este caso pues ya vimos que son 10
ceros entonces este número de aquí es
justo ese 10 a la 10 que estamos
poniendo por acá tomamos este número y
lo dividimos entre esa potencia y
entonces nos queda un punto decimal por
acá y por eso nos queda 8.23
para no modificar el número también
tenemos que multiplicarlo por ese mismo
número y entonces nos queda una
expresión más simple más concisa y más
fácil de manejar entonces ya que
terminamos de escribir todos estos
números en su notación científica lo que
vamos a hacer es hacer una
multiplicación
bueno otra cosa que se puede decir aquí
es que si todavía te suena muy raro toma
estos dos números y multiplica los y vas
a ver cómo te queda justo este número
entonces digamos que tenemos un número
muy chiquito por ejemplo punto 0 0 0 0 0
6 4 y lo queremos multiplicar por un
número muy grande aunque hay por ejemplo
podemos multiplicar por 3 200 000 000 00
queremos hacer esta multiplicación tú
qué opinas tampoco no se ve súper
complicada y enredada y así como que
seguro nos vamos a equivocar haciendo
una cuenta no sé si te parezca así
seguramente lo puedes hacer muy bien con
mucho cuidado pero ojalá encuentres al
igual que yo que si escribimos estos
números en notación científica todo se
vuelve muchísimo más sencillo y que
entonces vamos a empezar por escribir
este número en notación científica
tenemos aquí el punto decimal buscamos
el primer número distinto de 0 que es el
entonces nos queda 6.4 x y tenemos que
recorrer el punto decimal
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis lugares a
la derecha entonces es por 10 al menos 6
y ahora vamos a escribir la anotación
científica de este otro número el primer
número distinto de 0 desde la izquierda
es este 3.2 por y tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 lugares a la derecha del 3 10
a la 11 aunque hay queremos multiplicar
estos dos números de hecho déjame lo
pongo por aquí si queremos multiplicar
este número con este
otro número pero esto lo podemos
reescribir de otra forma que lo vimos en
el vídeo pasado podemos reacomodar cada
uno de estos términos entonces esto es
igual a 6.4 por 3.2 por 10 a la menos 6
y por 10 al 11 ahora podemos poner unos
paréntesis por acá
y empezar por hacer esta multiplicación
aunque la verdad no quiero sacar ninguna
calculadora entonces vamos a hacerlo por
aquí 6.4 por 3.2
a ver 2 x 4 es 8 2 por 6 2 y vamos con
el siguiente número ponemos nuestro 0
por aquí 3 por 4 12 y llevamos 13 por 6
18 y 119 entonces tenemos que sumar 8
082 más 24 9 más 110 y llevamos 11 más
12 y para terminar lo único que nos
falta es contar cuántos números hay a la
derecha del punto decimal en estos dos
números aquí hay uno y aquí hay otro
entonces hay dos números a la derecha
del punto decimal
así es que aquí tenemos que poner un
número dos números a la derecha del
punto decimal 6.4 por tres puntos 2
es igual 20.48 y esto lo estamos
multiplicando por 10 al menos 6 por 10 a
la 11 pero esto es muy fácil de obtener
porque tenemos la misma base que estamos
celebrando a distintos exponentes y los
estamos multiplicando entonces como
vimos ya en los vídeos de exponentes
esto es igual a la base que es 10
elevado a la potencia menos 6 más 11 y
menos 6 más 11 es simplemente un 5 y
listo
y bueno dije que ya estaba listo pero me
equivoqué aunque hay porque aquí esto sí
se parece mucho a la anotación
científica pero no está exactamente en
la anotación científica aunque se puede
simplificar un poquito más en donde pues
aquí porque aquí tenemos dos números a
la izquierda del punto decimal y
podríamos tener simplemente uno pero
resulta que es muy fácil convertir este
número a su notación científica estricta
y para hacer esto lo único que tenemos
que hacer es multiplicar por un 1 pero
no un 1 en esta forma como lo acabamos
de escribir en la forma de 10 entre 10
para que pues para dividir este 10 entre
10 y dejar un 1 entre 10 de este lado y
poner un por 10 de este lado porque este
1 entre 10 lo que hace es recorrer este
punto decimal un lugar a la izquierda y
pues este por 10 no nos afecta en la
anotación científica
lo que tenemos que hacer es sumar los
exponentes esto es igual a 10 a la 51
que es 6 y de este lado tenemos 20.48
entre 10
eso es 2.0 48 y ahora si ya tenemos esto
en notación científica que ya
multiplicamos estos dos números y lo
único que hicimos fue convertir este
número a su notación científica este
otro número a su notación científica
después reacomodamos los términos
pusimos a los dieces de un lado y a los
otros números del otro lado calculamos
las cosas y listo
super sencillo no bueno ahora vamos a
hacer una división y bueno para hacer la
división vamos a usar exactamente los
mismos números tomemos por ejemplo este
número está en su notación científica
3.2 por 10 a la 11 y dividamos lo entre
este numerito aunque su mutación
científica es esta entonces vamos a
escribirlo porque 6.4 por 10 al menos 6
entonces para hacer esta división al
igual que la multiplicación podemos
cambiar de lugar todos sus términos
entonces esto es igual a 3.2 entre 6.4
por 10 a la 11 entre 10 al menos 6 haber
acerca de esta división de dos números
aquí lo que podemos hacer es notar que
este es un múltiplo de es de hecho si
tomamos este número y lo multiplicamos
por 2 nos queda este entonces esta cosa
es un medio y un medio es punto 5
punto 5 este punto 5 lo tenemos que
multiplicar por 10 a la 11 entre 10 a la
menos 6 pero resulta que 10 a la 11
entre 10 a la menos 6 es igual a 10 a la
11 x 10 al menos 6 a la menos 1 qué
demonios estamos haciendo aquí pues para
entender esto tenemos que utilizar las
leyes de los exponentes recuerden que si
estamos dividiendo entre un número eso
es equivalente a multiplicar por ese
número pero elevarlo a la potencia menos
1 ahora por otra regla de los exponentes
si tenemos una base elevado a un
exponente y luego todo ese número lo
elevamos a otro exponente eso es
exactamente igual a tomar la base y
elevarlo al número que nos queda de
multiplicar los dos exponentes aunque
hay menos 6 x menos uno es simplemente
así es que aquí nos queda 10 a la 11 x
10 a los 6 que es igual a 10 a la 10 y 7
y hay puras reglas de los exponentes
entonces aquí tenemos puntos 5 de esta
división por 10 a la 17 que nos queda de
esta división es puntos 5 por 10 al 17 y
listo esta es la respuesta correcta al
menos la respuesta correcta de esta
división sin embargo si quieres
escribirlo en notación científica te
falta un paso todavía necesitamos un
número menor o igual que 9 y mayor o
igual que 1 y bueno lo único que tenemos
que hacer aquí es multiplicar por 10 de
este lado cerca del punto 5 pero para no
modificar el número también tenemos que
dividir entre 10 a ver entonces tenemos
10 por punto 5
es igual a 5 y por aquí estamos
multiplicando por 10 a la 17 pero luego
dividiendo entre 10 y dividir entre 10
es como multiplicar por 10 a la menos 1
aunque hay entonces este 1 entre 10 es
como 10 al menos 1 y 10 a las 17 por 10
a la menos uno tiene la misma base
entonces nada más sumamos los exponentes
y nos queda 10 al 16 y
listo esto es lo que obtenemos de esta
división